The universe is a tantalizing realm of billowing
galaxies, terrorizing black holes, mysterious
planets, and then...we get to asteroids.
These lone grey worlds seem to have all the
hype right now and, if we have so much going
on in the universe, why are we so focused
on sending spacecraft to these drifting rocks?
I mean they’re not exactly easy to explore.
Japan’s Aerospace Exploration Agency learned
that the literal “hard way” when their
spacecraft, Hayabusa2, had to launch a “bullet”
into the rocky surface of asteroid Ryugu.
(Of course it was for data collecting purposes)
but it was never supposed to be that way.
JAXA scientists anticipated the asteroid to
have regolith, or a powdery surface of pulverized
material of ice, and dust This would be easy
for Hayabusa2 to collect a sample of and add
to the regolith material that was brought
back from asteroid Itokawa on the first Hayabusa
mission.
But upon arrival, they were met with the opposite;
a graveled hard terrain.
With some quick thinking, scientists made
adjustments to their collection tactics before
our buddy H2 made its landing–and in doing
so, here on earth, they entirely replicated
the surface of an asteroid and shot it with
a copy of their sampling instrument.
All their testing proved successful when,
on February 22nd, 2019 the spacecraft blasted
the surface of Ryugu, collecting a piece of
the asteroid, which is now is on its way back
to us.
We expect H2’s valiant return in 2020.
5.
But that’s not the only sample we’re expecting
to arrive to Earth in the coming years.
NASA’s OSIRIS-REx spacecraft is on a mission
as well, to investigate another asteroid named
Bennu.
Scientists recently discovered by chance that
this is a rare class of asteroid, which ejects
its own mass into space leaving a trail of
tinier rocks in its wake.
6.
But Hayabusa2 and Osiris-rex didn’t travel
so far to check if asteroids are bullet-proof
and watch them throw up.
I mean they did, but more importantly NASA
says that asteroids are time capsules of our
solar system, and these investigative missions
are a way to unravel a few mysteries we still
have about how it all formed and how we got
here.
7.
Like one of the biggest asteroids may have
delivered the elements of life to Earth.
Scientists believe that asteroids like Bennu
which are carbon-rich, collided with our planet
during its formative years.
And while the rocks didn’t have oceans on
them, they could have had water molecules
lurking within its mineral structure, and
helped begin the vast life we now know and
love.
There’s also the idea that while earth might
have been given life from an asteroid, they
may have also supplied the foundations for
the planets themselves.
8.
In the early beginnings of our solar system,
there were just tiny particles of dust, made
of rock, metal, and ice swirling around our
young sun.
But as time passed some bits fell into the
sun and others stuck together; creating asteroids,
but maybe also getting bigger into planetary
bodies.
We have evidence that previous asteroids we’ve
visited with NASA’s Dawn spacecraft, Vesta
and Ceres, were internally layered with materials,
with the core being the densest part.Indicating
both asteroids were growing to be planets
but they never gathered enough material to
do so.
So an asteroid could be a leftover relic from
that early evolution period of our solar system
that we’re still trying to figure out.
9.
But now that I’ve explained some ways asteroids
are awesome, there’s always a little disclaimer
and this one is that asteroids can be hazardous
to earth.
We actually have a program called the Planetary
Defense Coordination Office and they use a
collection of instruments in the Near-Earth
Object (NEO) Observations Program to keep
tabs on any and all asteroids that flyby,
or enter our atmosphere.NASA is even working
on a redirect mission called DART where Bruce
Willis takes a team of oil riggers – jk,
There’s no Bruce, but this is a real mission.
And emerging research like this simulation
from John Hopkins University shows that it’s
much more difficult to destroy an asteroid
than we previously thought.
So this all may be new to you, but we’ve
actually been hunting asteroids for a while
now.
Back in the early 2000’s, NASA’s NEAR
Shoemaker was the first spacecraft to orbit
and land on an asteroid.
Now missions like this are standard when going
to small bodies with OSIRIS REx, Hayabusa1
and 2, Rosetta/Philae, and New Horizons.
And they’ve taught us so much already.
Hayabusa2, although not back yet with its
sample, has already detected that the Ryugu
asteroid is drier than anticipated and that
it’s quite young, only around 100 million
years old.
This suggests that wherever it stemmed from
was probably devoid of water, too.
Which might change our current understanding
of what the universe looked like 100 million
years ago.
And OSIRIS RE-x, remember lucked out with
Bennu being an “active asteroid.”
Out of the 8,000 asteroids discovered, there
have been just 12 observed releasing their
material into space.
So all observations from Bennu are valuable
and it has plenty of time to prepare for its
sample mission in July 2020.
But what is in store for the future?
Let me introduce Mission Psyche.
NASA wants to send a spacecraft, for the first
time, to a nearly entirely metal asteroid
named Psyche.
Psyche is special because it might be a piece
of a metallic core that’s similar to Earth’s
that we can ACTUALLY study.
Earth’s core is way too hot to investigate
and now it’s our opportunity to do so and
understand how Earth and other rocky planets
formed.
Plus, the center of our magnetic field is
our metallic core, sooo this might help us
understand that too.
(hopefully) NASA’s estimated arrival to
Psyche will be in 2026.
So floating space rocks such as asteroids,
are unique to our understanding of our universe.
They may hold the key answers to our burning
questions and all we have to do is capture
them.
One spacecraft at a time.
Still wanna know more about the missions ahead?
Comment down below on the specifics you’re
looking for and check out this video about
Oumuamua, the mysterious interstellar asteroid
that flew right by us.
Subscribe for more science in your day and
thanks for watching seeker.